[Musique]
bien dans le débat sur France 24 la
Russie a revendiqué de nouvelles frappes
massives sur les infrastructures de
l'Ukraine et contre les cibles de
commandement militaires Moscou a frappé
des installations énergétiques à l'ouest
du pays la ville de vive était privée à
30% d'électricité au sud zapporijah
était littéralement pilonné aujourd'hui
par une salve de 12 missiles les
installations énergétiques de ni pro ont
également été touchés à Kiev les sirènes
d'alerte ont résonné plus de 5 heures
d'affilée ce matin en réaction le G7
s'est réuni virtuellement en urgence en
présence de volody mirzelinski et a
promis de demander des comptes à
Vladimir Poutine les frappes massives de
la Russie en Ukraine sont un signe de
faiblesse à réagi le secrétaire général
de l'OTAN Joe Biden a promis de livrer
des systèmes perfectionnés de défense
entière tout comme l'Allemagne l'Union
européenne estime que les frappes sur
les cibles civiles s'apparentent à des
crimes de faire alors la réponse
occidentale est-elle suffisamment ferme
face à Poutine et bien on va poser la
question à mes invités j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés le général Christian
keno bonsoir vous êtes ancien chef
d'état-major particulier à l'Elysée
bienvenue à vous en face de vous
régisses chanter journaliste
correspondant à BBC spécialiste des
anciennes républiques soviétiques vous
êtes correspondant pour France 24 et RFI
coauteur avec Stéphane suoron de volodi
mirzelinski dans la tête d'un héros et
c'est paru chez Robert Lafont bienvenue
Régis Thomas Friant est avec nous
bonsoir fondateur et directeur général
de l'Institut open diplomatie nous avons
avec nous par Skype de Kiev tetiana
ogarkova tetiana bonsoir journaliste
responsable du département international
de
Ukrain Cry 6 Media Center bienvenue à
vous
bonsoir
les Occidentaux ont donc réaffirmé leur
soutien à Kiev après la vague de
bombardements russes bombardement qui se
sont donc poursuivis je vous le disais
ce mardi notamment sur des sites
énergétiques Ukrainiens on fait d'abord
le point en images avec Marco
dans le ciel de Kiev un épée nuage
flotte toujours au-dessus de la ville au
lendemain des bombardements russes les
sirènes résonnent régulièrement les
habitants eux désertent les lieux
publics et ceux qu'elle feutre dans le
métro comme au premier jour de la guerre
on ne pensait pas que cela se
reproduirait dans le centre-ville
cela m'a surpris qu'il ne vise pas des
infrastructures
c'est du terrorisme
on comprend qu'on n'est pas à l'abri
chez nous
dans le reste du pays les bombardements
Russes se poursuivent si blanc notamment
on les installations énergétiques comme
Malvi vous ni pro pour faire face à ses
problèmes l'Ukraine demande ainsi à ses
habitants de limiter leur consommation
d'électricité sur la ligne de front les
combats s'intensifient à Sauvian ce que
des missiles ont frappé cet immeuble
résidentiel des scènes
identiques à zapoidja
je me suis endormie à 4h30 du matin il y
a eu deux explosions puis une troisième
c'était très bruyant les choses ont volé
dans la chambre je suis allée dans
l'entrée les enfants et les
petits-enfants pleurer
de leur côté les forces russes assurent
avoir visé des objectifs militaires
Ukrainiens
les forces armées russes ont continué à
mener des frappes massives avec des
armes longues portées de haute précision
depuis des bases terrestres ou maritimes
sur des sites militaires et des
installations électriques de l'Ukraine
les objectifs des frappes ont été
atteints toutes les installations
désignées ont été touchées ces nouvelles
frappes russes interviennent après un
déluge de missiles lancé lundi sur des
cibles civiles en représailles à
l’explosion du pont de Crimée le
week-end dernier des frappes très
critiquées par la communauté
internationale qui dénonce deux
possibles crimes de guerre
on va tout de suite écouter le
secrétaire général de l'OTAN c'était cet
après-midi
l'Ukraine à l'avantage et continue de
remporter des victoires significatives
pendant que la Russie se livre toujours
à des attaques horribles et
indiscriminés sur des civils et des
infrastructures clés Inde critical
le président Poutine est en train de
perdre en Ukraine
ces tentatives d'annexion
sa mobilisation partielle et sa
rhétorique nucléaire représente
l'escalade la plus significative depuis
le début de la guerre et montre que
cette guerre ne se déroule pas comme il
l'avait prévu
bien sûr démarrer avec vous puisque vous
êtes à Kiev Poutine donc ils continuent
de revendiquer le pilonnage de ces
villes de ces infrastructures
énergétiques de l'autre côté donc l'OTAN
on a entendu secrétaire général donc il
renouvelle son soutien à l'Ukraine en
parlant de livraison de système de
défense entière le G7 va dans le même
sens
quelles sont les réactions justement à
cette mobilisation
occidentale est-ce qu'elle est
suffisante
l'objectif est très clair il a de fait
militaire de la Russie la restauration
de l'unité territoriale de l'Ukraine et
la punition très nécessaire après le
conflit parce que si on tolère
l'agression comme ça ça veut dire qu'on
attaque les principes même de notre
civilisation ce que serait extrêmement
dangereux nous seulement pour l'Ukraine
mais pour tout le pays pour l'Europe et
pour tout l'Occident en général
christiano pour rebondir sur ce que
vient de dire l'éthanol l'objectif
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est la
fermeture occidentale du ciel ukrainien
la fermeture on arrive jamais à fermer
complètement mais il est évident que
la décision a été prise de renforcer les
systèmes de neutralisation des missiles
il faut dire que ça existe déjà puisque
les
Ukrainiens dans les dernières frappes on
ont quand même arrêté neutraliser 43% ce
qui est quand même
assez cons si vous voulez et donc le les
Allemands vont donner un système les
Américains
le système allemand et les Américains
vont donner d'autres avec d'une portée
peut un peu un peu plus importante qui
peuvent atteindre jusqu'à 100 180 km le
les missiles en croisière donc ces
systèmes de défense entière
qui puisque les Russes la seule
alternative qu'ils aient c'est les
missiles parce que il ne progresse pas
ils sont incapables de progresser par
les forces terrestres de faire la
décision sur le terrain donc ils
essaient de toucher le moral et de
détruire le moral des Ukrainiens et de
détruire leurs infrastructures et ça
quand même de l'effet sur le plan de
l'alimentation électrique sur le plan
des des pots de carburant etc ce n'est
pas négligeable mais est-ce que ça veut
dire que le terrestre passe en deuxième
position
le terrestre toujours d'actualité les
objectifs des Ukrainiens c'est c'est de
prendre de débarrasser les Russes les
faire sortir de la rive droite d'une
Nieppe et donc je pense qu'ils vont
qu'ils vont y arriver à avant l'hiver et
après le le maître du terrain pendant
quelques temps sera le général hiver
général hiver lente en attendant donc se
boucler aérien qui est vraiment
fortement demandé par volody mirzelinski
Régis jante s'est frappes massives
russes sont un signe de faiblesse de la
Russie a dit le secrétaire général de
l'OTAN comment vous qui évidemment on
sait que vous êtes notre correspondant
en Géorgie vous connaissez bien tous ces
pays frontaliers comment on réagit
là-bas et à ce qu'effectivement cette
idée de bouclier aérien occidentale pour
protéger l'Ukraine des frappes russes et
devient vraiment la priorité aujourd'hui
depuis le début je crois que les
Ukrainiens les réclament depuis le
presque le premier jour de la guerre
effectivement donc ça c'est vraiment
extrêmement important ce serait la
réponse occidentale qui serait
différente parce que plus axée justement
elle est encore partielle 43% des
missiles de ce lundi ont été ont été
abattus il reste 57 % qui sont tombés
qui ont tué je crois un peu plus de 20
personnes etc et qui ont porté des coups
à des infrastructures civiles quoi oui
effectivement il y a l'idée vous l'avez
souligné général d'une d'un fond
défaites certes une Russie qui reculent
en permanence depuis le 29 août en
réalité incapable qui n'a aucune
victoire à enregistrer de depuis cette
date et effectivement la nouvelle
stratégie mise en place avec la
nomination de ce nouveau général etc
consiste à essayer de stabiliser on va
dire ce front avant l'hiver avant
l'hiver en effet toute la rhétorique
aussi sur le nucléaire s'inscrit dans ce
cadre là ça veut pas dire que la Russie
ne va pas gagner ça ne veut pas dire que
la Russie n'est pas dangereuse
évidemment mais c'est ça le fond
effectivement de la séquence oui oui
mais elle peut continuer à pilonner
longtemps c'est ça en fait poser la
question ça reste encore un certain pour
discuter parfois avec des gens qui
essaient d'évaluer le stock d'armes
russes il est très incertain c'est
difficile on sait que les missiles les
armes disons qu'ils sont utilisés même
ce lundi sont assez disparaître il y a
même des missiles à vocation plutôt
de défense qui ont été utilisées pour
l'attaque des drones iraniens donc on
sait qu'il y a une il y a une
problématique et une des questions qui
se posent depuis le début je me souviens
lorsque autour de Mars Avril à peu près
un missile balistique avait été utilisé
sur l'aéroport de venitsa donc assez
loin du front plutôt à l'ouest on sait
que Monsieur Poutine était très très en
colère à ce moment-là en disant mais
pourquoi est-ce que vous gâchez un
missile sur un aéroport secondaire ça
donc la problématique existe
certainement alors les évaluations des
des stocks son sujet d'art caution le
au départ il devrait être ils devaient
être de 13 ans peut-être à mon avis un
peu plus
je parle pas de ds400
sur ce il y en a un certain nombre qui
ont été déjà consommés et il faut savoir
que l'industrie
militaire russe est capable d'en
produire sans à 200 par an de
déjà utilisé plus de 80 même avec
aujourd'hui
de de la centaine et vous dites c'est
qu'il lui en reste la moitié c'est tout
je sais pas mais il lui en reste mais le
problème c'est le renouvellement et le
renouvellement est difficile parce que
il dispose des tôles d'acier disposent
des explosifs mais ils vont ils sont
limités en système électronique de
guidage parce que l'Occident a
complètement taré ceci et donc les
Chinois qui pourraient leur enfournir ne
leur fournissent pas parce que si
j'exping veut conserver les relations en
particulier économique avec les
États-Unis donc
il reste la Corée du Nord je sais pas
s'ils ont s'ils en ont beaucoup la Corée
du Nord a fourni un certain nombre
d'obus à la Russie mais mais voilà mais
on est quand même dans une problématique
pas forcément de tarissement absolu mais
de diminution parce que sur les 1300 les
Russes doivent en conserver pour
protéger leur système nucléaire et donc
ils peuvent pas ramener le niveau à zéro
on est donc en fait quand le secrétaire
général de l'OTAN on dit finalement la
Russie est en train de perdre la guerre
c'est pas totalement faux à vous écouter
vous savez
ce qu'on appelle le brouillard de la
guerre je ne sais pas ce que je suis
certain c'est que Poutine bah va
disparaître à terme je sais pas quand
mais il va être éliminé ça c'est un
autre un autre sujet on va on va y
revenir Thomas friand vous qui êtes
spécialiste du multilatéralisme est-ce
que bon le G7 c'est pas la première fois
qu'il se réunit bien sûr est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'était différent est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression d'union
face à Poutine il est très clair que sur
les depuis l'annexion de la Crimée en
2014 le G7 a retrouvé une forme de de
vocation parce que la Russie en a été
exclu je rappelle que
j'ai 8 ans à l'initiative de la France
Vladimir Poutine et la Russie avait été
intégré à la fin des années 90 dans le
club du G7 et puis à un moment
l'invasion de l'annexion pardon de la
Crimée elle en a été exclu et donc il y
a eu deux phases depuis ce moment-là la
phase de l'air Trump où on parlait de G6
plus un parce que le G7 fonctionnait
enfin existait mais ne fonctionnait plus
notamment le sommet du G7 qui était sous
président américain n'a même pas eu lieu
en 2000-2020
et là depuis l'air Biden et le le cette
crise qui a redonné du sens au G7 comme
à l'OTAN d'ailleurs le système
fonctionne maintenant l'unité du G7 ne
fait pas le succès du G7 puisqu'il y a
beaucoup à faire pour pour apporter une
aide utile à l'Ukraine ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que quand on
lit la déclaration du G7 de ce soir tout
y est sur le papier c'est parfait tout
seul juste
à dire c'est la condamnation des
bombardements indiscriminés des civils
il y a la condamnation des référendum
illégaux d'annexion de des quatre blast
qui ont été
opérés récemment il y a le rappel au
fait que la Russie a complètement rompu
avec son rôle de membre de permanents du
concept de sécurité c'est à dire de
garantir
l'intégrité de la Charte des Nations
Unies et et même pire que ça elle l'a
viol tous les jours il y a la
condamnation de l'escalade de la
rhétorique nucléaire il y a le point
d'attention très particulier sur la
centrale de zaporigia on va revenir
d'ailleurs on a tous les éléments qui
s'y trouvent maintenant ce qui est
intéressant c'est ce qu'il n'y a pas
dans le communiqué c'est-à-dire la liste
très concrète sur le plan capacitaire et
militaire de ce qui va être mis en place
c'est normal que ça ne s'y trouve pas
les armes qui vont être
interpréter ça de la façon suivante
c'est que l'Occident qui ne veut pas
rentrer dans une logique de nourrir le
narratif poutinien d'un combat entre la
Russie et l'Occident parce que ça serait
vraiment l'aboutissement d'un
effondrement du multilatéralisme et des
Nations Unies en particulier doit
avancer discrètement c'est à dire
équiper les Ukrainiens sans jamais
s'afficher et en terme de système bien
entendu et de capacité à employer de
façon autonome les systèmes faute de
quoi on va nourrir l'escalade et pas
seulement l'escalade de Poutine lui-même
mais une escalade peut-être un peu plus
internationale avec d'autres États qui
pourraient juger que ça n'est pas
important que l'Occident s'investisse
directement donc on ne dit pas tout dans
le communiqué c'est ça un petit peu ce
que vous nous dites on va écouter volo
dix meilleurs zeninski
je vous demande de renforcer l'effort
général pour aider et financièrement à
la création d'un bouclier aérien pour
l'Ukraine des millions de personnes
seront reconnaissantes pour une telle
assistance
vous avez senti que le front européen
que le front occidental était plus fort
cette fois j'ai vu que l'Union
européenne estimait par exemple que les
frappes sur les cibles civils
s'apparentait maintenant à des crimes de
guerre elle la redit il y a eu
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de corps
exhumés aujourd'hui en Ukraine est-ce
que vous avez l'impression que voilà que
justement dans le communiqué il n'y a
peut-être pas tout mais que dans les
actes et bien il y a plus de
mobilisation
justement c'est toujours on est toujours
affronté au même problème puisque au
niveau de la rhétorique au niveau de
parole tout allait relativement bien
depuis le début de ce conflit en février
2022 donc il y a c'est très clair que
tous les pays européens je sais le temps
même et se mettait clairement du côté de
l'Ukraine mais il y avait toujours des
comment on dit le diable est dans les
détails puisque quand il s'agissait de
l'envoi des armements où il y avait
certains délais parfois courts parfois
trop longs le système à rester qui était
promis justement encore en été le
système allemand va être livré
prochainement mais il fallait attendre
justement cette attaque massive très
cruelle de la Russie pour se précipiter
donc c'est toujours des le passage à
l'acte qui qui démontrent la vraie
solidarité et donc l'essentiel c'est de
ne pas se perdre dans les formules de
voilà qu'on est très concernés qu'on est
solidaire mais de justement de de
joindre les efforts très très réel dans
cette dans ce combat on comprend bien
sûr les les inquiétudes et les peurs de
partenaires occidentaux parce que
personne ne veut que ça passe au stade
de la guerre nucléaire c'est cette
crainte sont justifiées étant donné
qu'on sent que Poutine commence le temps
perdu en fait le lien avec la réalité
donc il est capable de pas mal de choses
très
imprévisibles donc il faut faire
attention mais à la fois
l'Ukraine sera la première à ne pas
avoir l'intérêt de prolonger cette
guerre on a toujours l'impression que il
y a cette entente sur que le fait que
oui Poutine ne doit pas gagner mais il y
a pas de véritable entente sur le fait
que le craindre apporté vraiment dans
cette guerre et emporter rapidement pour
nous quand on est dans le concret quand
on est en Ukraine chaque nouveau jour il
apporte de nouveau mort et ce sont pas
pour nous les mots les mots abstraits ce
sont souvent nos amis quelqu'un qu'on
que c'est quelqu'un de la famille quand
il y a des explosions quand c'est votre
enfant qui vous dit comme par exemple ma
fille hier nous dit que maman où
l'explosion était d'une telle ampleur
que je croyais que c'était à côté de
nous donc j'étais à côté j'étais loin
d'elle j'étais dans le tranquille
arrivée vers qui donc quand ça vous
touche concrètement humainement vous
avez tout intérêt que ça se termine vite
et donc avec cette solidarité verbale
qui est là on veut voir vraiment la
solidarité dans les actes qui nous
permettra d'avancer vite les troupes
craignaient donc déjà démontré de quoi
ils étaient capables les gars qui à côté
de garçon aussi d'une manière peut-être
pas moins spectaculaire mais quand même
donc il faut joindre des efforts
concrets et réels et dans la réalité qui
permettront de terminer cette guerre au
plus vite possible général question à
keno alors évidemment les Russes sont un
discours différent ils disent que
alimenter les armes à alimenter
justement l'armement ukrainien je cite
le porte-parole du Kremlin ce conflit ne
sera que plus long et pénible pour la
partie ukrainienne ils ont évidemment le
discours totalement inverse jusqu'où
l'OTAN peut-il aller donc là on voit
qu'il va quand même plus loin avec tout
un système vous le disez vous le disiez
anti-défense aérien jusqu'où peut-il
aller sans effectivement que les
Occidentaux soient belligérants est-ce
qu'il y a une ligne rouge là en fait que
Poutine pourrait utiliser
l'OTAN juridiquement ne peut pas
intervenir parce que l'Ukraine n'est pas
membre de l'OTAN et à mon avis je suis
pas sûr qu'elle le soit un jour si vous
voulez donc le les limites les limites
de de l'OTAN sont très nettes le l'OTAN
lourd par exemple pour parler vous voyez
ce que j'ai en fait il y a une sorte on
a rajouté
des États membres de l'OTAN fournissent
de l'armement à l'Ukraine c'est autre
chose mais c'est pas l'OTAN en tant que
tel qu'il fournit de l'armement il forme
aussi des Ukrainiens
entre justement belligérance parce que
c'est toujours les occidentaux font la
guerre sans la faire
les c'est pas d'hier les Ukrainiens sont
formés depuis 2014 en particulier prend
les Britanniques donc et il y a des gens
qui sont formés à l'heure actuelle les
les servants
Ukrainiens des canons françaises ont été
formés en France sur ce matériel ce qui
est ce qui est normal donc là on ne
dépasse pas non une fois les pays de
l'OTAN ne sont pas belligérants
l'OTAN n'est pas belligérante c'est là
où l'ambiguïté diplomatique est
importante et utile c'est que on ne peut
on ne souhaite pas entrer en guerre
contre la Russie on souhaite juste
permettre à l'Ukraine de préserver sa
souveraineté un territoriale et pouvoir
retrouver sa paix donc c'est important
de volontairement mettre toutes les
précautions d'usage pour éviter de
nourrir l'idée selon laquelle l'Occident
mènerait une guerre contre la Russie
parce que ça n'est pas ce qui est
souhaité
celui-là et aujourd'hui de dire que en
fait il mène une guerre contre
l'Occident et qu'aujourd'hui de dire
finalement ce conflit sera d'autant plus
long que l'Occident justement aide
l'Ukraine c'est en fait entre vos mains
c'est ce que dit la Russie je dirais oui
non puisque en même temps on voit bien
que la Russie prend bien garde de ne pas
utiliser de mobiligérance et je
reviendrai pas sur l'historique mais il
y a toute une gradation dans la manière
dont on qualifie effectivement
l'intervention ou la fourniture d'armes
par les pays occidentaux membres de
l'OTAN mais pas au titre de l'OTAN donc
donc la Russie fait aussi très très bien
la différence effectivement quoi mais
après effectivement et c'est là que je
crois que l'Occident a tout intérêt à se
mobiliser et à aider l'ukraines c'est
plus l'objectif de Monsieur Poutine et
de être son entourage je viens d'écrire
par exemple un portrait de Monsieur
patron chef du Conseil de sécurité et ce
qui est en Russie qui est une sorte de
d'idéologue en quelque sorte parce que
c'est une coquille vide ce Conseil de
sécurité donc c'est plutôt quelqu'un qui
qui alimente monsieur Poutine ou qui qui
est verbalise en quelque sorte son
idéologie et la et ses ambitions et là
sont des gens qui qui visent clairement
l'Occident c'est l'Occident la cible en
réalité à travers l'Ukraine en réalité
donc il faut pas il faut pas croire que
et je ces jours-ci sur les réseaux
sociaux il y avait une vidéo d'une
conférence de presse du général de
Gaulle de 61 pendant la crise des
missiles et c'est précisément ce qu'il
est expliquait le général qui disait
derrière ça si si les régimes de
talitaire dictatorio gagnent et bien ça
va forcément affecter le le la solidité
si je puis dire politique des régimes
occidentaux c'est ça l'enjeu en fait le
il y a un vrai conflit il y a un conflit
entre la Russie et les États-Unis c'est
le conflit le sol et le conflit
essentiel Biden les Américains ont
décidé de ramener la Russie à un niveau
tel qu'elle soit incapable dans le futur
de mener ce type d'action ça c'est le le
la lutte cardinale dans ce système il y
a les Ukrainiens mais les
Ukrainiens sont
pardonnez-moi de dire c'est un joueur de
deuxième catégorie par rapport à ce
conflit même si
mais si on raisonne en termes
stratégique le conflit est États-Unis
URSS pardon Russie donc ancienne
ancienne
URSS volody miRs en tout cas parce qu'il
y a un acteur dont on n'a pas parlé dont
il faut parler c'est bien sûr la
Biélorussie puisqu'elle Alexandre Lucas
and Co et le grand allié de Vladimir
Poutine et volody merzelinski accuse
Moscou justement de vouloir entraîner la
Biélorussie dans le conflit le président
ukrainien a même demandé une mission
d'observation internationale à la
frontière entre les deux pays on va
l'écouter on va écouter également la
réaction de Catherine Colonna la
ministre française des Affaires
étrangères
la Russie essaye d'entraîner directement
le Belarus dans cette guerre jouant sur
la provocation que nous préparerions une
attaque contre ce pays
mais afin d'éliminer complètement cette
provocation de supprimer ces récits de
nous cacher de supprimer même
l'hypothèse de toute menace présumée de
notre part nous offrons notre solution
une mission d'observateur internationaux
peut être stationné à la frontière de
l'Ukraine et du Belarus pour surveiller
la situation sécuritaire
les conversations des dirigeants du G7
qui se réuniront cet après-midi la
question de la Biélorussie sera très
certainement très certainement à
l'agenda car il faut lancer un
avertissement à ce pays tout soutient
supplémentaire à la guerre que mène la
Russie du GRAINE entrainerait des
sanctions supplémentaires je vous
rappelle que la Biélorussie est sous
sanction d'ores et déjà Saint-Étienne
que peut constituer Lucas and Co et la
Biélorussie
les scions avec le coaching coup et bien
compliqué parce que depuis le début de
cette invasion on a vu les hésitations
sans fond et puis les coups qui étaient
poussés qui étaient vraiment poussé par
Poutine d'entrée directement dans cette
guerre en plusieurs fois on sait très
bien que Bila rousse avait prêté tout
son territoire pour cette grande
invasion de fin février mars donc on
peut pas dire que le vélo rouge n'est
pas dans son conflit parce qu'il est
plusieurs missiles ont été envoyés
depuis le territoire de biéloruss mais
on sait que bon le coachenko a
contrairement aux Poutine n'a pas
vraiment perdu le lien avec la réalité
on a l'impression qu'elle comprend très
bien que cette participation directe
dans la guerre serait la fente
l'infanterie sur de son pouvoir de son
régime parce qu'il sait très bien que la
population la population des bulles
rouges se sont en fait très très contre
cette guerre ils n'ont rien contre les
Ukrainiens contrairement aux Russes qui
ont toujours ce complexe d'un pire
un peu triste de retrouver une fois de
plus là je rebondis à ce que avait dit
le général de ce vieux cliché de les
États-Unis contre contre l'Union
soviétique c'est la Russie c'est un
empire et bien sûr ils sont réflexe le
cache une cour par contre il est quand
même ce réflexe de réaliste et comprend
très bien qu'il dispose pas de troupes
importantes que il peut pas être faire
confiance vraiment à leur comportement
on a vu aussi les actions de de
partisans qui ont été actifs un
biélorusses donc lui il hésite il fait
tout le possible pour dire oui à Poutine
et pour ne rien faire ceci dure depuis 7
mois mais aujourd'hui ça peut changer ça
peut changer on exclut pas ce risque et
bien sûr que ça va compliquer la vie
pour les trop peu créé ne me doute pas
on n'est plus en février 2022 l'armée
idéale les troupes sont à côté de la
frontière et donc on sera prêt à les
accueillir ça vous êtes d'accord est-ce
que vient de dire non c'est vraiment
important d'avoir si on sexe parce que
là il parle de une force commune c'est
ça biélorus et russe surtout monsieur
Poutine qui est en parle à vrai dire et
effectivement c'est un pays également on
l'a entendu
c'est ce que dit Tatiana effectivement
on a une population qui veut
radicalement contre cette guerre un
président Bélarus qui doit sa survie
politique à Monsieur Poutine parce que
il avait volé une élection souvenez-vous
crise de doute 2020 qui s'en était suivi
et s'il avait pas été soutenu par
Monsieur pouding il serait plus là donc
il lui doit quelque chose et en même
temps il sait très bien qu'il peut pas
aller dans la guerre donc il y a
toujours ce jeu de ça si vous voulez le
régime tient sur sur l'armée et et
l'instabilité enfin il y a absolument
aucun désir social en biais en
Biélorussie au Bélarus pour soutenir un
effort de guerre ça serait un
effondrement mais après il y a quand
même des signes assez inquiétant je veux
dire quand Poutine c'était au courant de
l'été
fait une un sommet bilatérale avec le
cachenko c'est pour annoncer qu'il va
équiper les sous koï de l'Armée de l'Air
Bel
à partir de tête nucléaire russe ça veut
dire qu'il déploie son armement
nucléaire sur d'autres terrains
s'ajoutent à ça que plus récemment c'est
à dire hier les fameux drones Iraniens
qui qui ont mené des frappes à travers
le pays venait venait ont été ont
décoller de la Biélorussie donc c'est
pas totalement enfin à la fois il y a
une grande prudence de la part de
location parce qu'il sait ce qu'il tient
ce qui est ce qui est en jeu pour lui
mais en même temps tout ce qu'il doit
faire pour pouvoir contenter le suzerin
Poutine il le fait et ça va aller en
s'accélérant sur la question du
nucléaire parce que juste un petit ajout
vous avez raison et en plus là
sur les questions nucléaires je peux
entrer dans le détail mais qui qui
pourrait les laisser augurer d'une sorte
de d'utilisation du Belarus pour la
menace nucléaire en tout cas donc il
pourrait acheminer un certain nombre de
missiles peut-être nucléaire en
Biélorussie général keno la guerre
nucléaire est pas d'actualité est né à
mon avis ne le sera pas parce que
bien compris la ligne rouge quoi fixé
byden en revanche ensuite concerne
labellion Russie
l'opinion publique comme vous le dites
et tout à fait opposée et l'armée
belorus ne vaut pas grand-chose l'armée
russe ne vaut pas grand-chose mais
l'armée bijoriste ne vous voit encore
moins et ouvrir un front une oui mais
générale donc ils n'ont qu'une aucune
expérience militaire ce n'est pas
vraiment une menace supplémentaire pour
le l'Ukraine mais ça obligera l'Ukraine
à déployé un rideau de troupes à la
frontière Bélarus ce qui diminuera leur
possibilité d'action dans d'autres
domaines
la conséquence mais
ce n'est pas
déterminant pour le sort de la bataille
et du coup est-ce que cette solution de
d'une mission
Thomas friand que propose Zelinski de
mission d'observation peut-être de l'ONU
enfin je sais pas très bien observation
internationale donc oui pour le moment
de l'ONU entre l'Ukraine et la
Biélorussie est-ce que par exemple ça
pourrait être un chemin diplomatique
possible inenvisageable puisque il
faudrait que ça passe par le Conseil de
sécurité évidemment la Russie
ça peut être envisageable après mission
d'observation veut certainement pas dire
mission d'interpellation on n'est pas là
sur un travail de garde frontière et
d'ailleurs donc quand on lit les
communiquer du G7 on a en effet les
éléments Catherine Colonna mentionne
c'est-à-dire un appel ressaisissement
entre guillemets de location avec la
menace de sanctions additionnelles et il
est propre que ça vienne il n'y a pas il
y a pas du tout ils n'ont les leaders du
G7 n'ont pas embrayé sur la demande de
zellins qui sur ce sujet c'est-à-dire
ils n'ont pas confirmé à ma connaissance
une augmentation
ils ont pas confirmé la fameuse mission
d'observation après peut-être que zélins
qui est venu à la table du G7 pour
mettre cette proposition elle est
peut-être toute neuve les pays du G7
vont l'examiner cette séquence G7 elle
est préparateur du sommet quelques temps
au niveau des ministres de la Défense
qui se tient demain donc il est possible
que dans la durée
ça soit l'occasion de sonder les États
qui seraient volontaires pour élaborer
une telle solution toujours en ayant
cette enjeu de certainement pas nourrir
la rhétorique russe de dire ça serait
l'Occident contre la Russie puisque ça
c'est le narratif que la Russie veut
installer qui est qui est un
effondrement total du système onusien si
ça se produit alors que personne n'y a
intérêt et donc les États qui pourraient
contribuer à une telle mission doivent
rester prudent sur ce que ça pourrait
impliquer dans la façon de nourrir le
narratif du crédit de toute façon ce
genre de mission n'a jamais servi à rien
ah bon donc moi là va ces élastiques il
a demandé à prendre des témoins mais en
effet sur le plan militaire ça
changerait pas la donne les missions de
l'OSCE dans le passé l'ont montré donc
ça c'est de on est dans le déclaratoire
donc pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
inscrit demande une telle mission
d'observation à votre avis Tatiana au
garkova le général keno qui a l'air de
dire que ça ne sert à rien
on sait pas c'est vrai que une
profession est toute neuve on sait qu'il
y avait d'autres demandes dans le passé
vous me faites par le président
précédent peu de reprocher de cours pour
des démissions dans le dos de base
occupé en 2014 donc oui je serai
d'accord de dire que pas mal de de
missions comme ça sont déclaratoires
justement mais je pense que vous le dit
merci cherchent à tout prix de mettre
justement un parking un autre un juge
entre les deux parties pour qu'il y ait
pas de de cette propagande parce que
faites attention ce que dit le cache and
Co hier location Kodi a dit hier que
nous allons répondre si le crime va nous
attaquer c'est exactement ce genre de
propos qu'il est avec tenu le 23 ou le
24 février donc il assurait vraiment
sérieusement que l'Ukraine allait
attaquer des Russie le 24 donc c'est
pour cette raison qu'elle avait prêté le
terroir trop Prusse qui était là par
ailleurs en entraînement depuis deux
semaines pour traverser et donc la
frontière ukrainienne etc donc c'est
consommation mélange là parce que on a
on a un peu marre de voir les les
mensonges en permanence de la Russie des
Russie de nos accusés que nous prions à
les attaquer ce qui n'est pas du tout
vrai et donc c'est par volonté de dire
que écouter ouvrez les yeux on sera pas
là à sur affirmer comment sont les
choses il y a un tiers qui sera là à
observer et à dire à à informer aussi
les partenaires occidentaux l'Ukraine de
ce qui se passe réellement sur le
terrain en une phrase ça serait un
succès diplomatique si c'était des États
non occidentaux qui menaient à bien
cette mission parce que là on aurait
des États du Sud avec un grand un grand
S qui pourrait témoigner de ce que de ce
que madame a dit c'est à dire que
l'Ukraine est de bonne foi quand elle
dit qu'elle ne tape pas la Biélorussie
et c'est une manière de dire voyez bien
qu'on ne veut pas attaquer le Belarus
puisqu'on est prêt à accepter des
observateurs internationaux donc c'est
une manière de casser en quelque sorte
cette cette tentative Russo bellarus de
dire que l'Ukraine provoquerait le
Belarus sur son territoire bien autre
chose à faire évidemment sur un peu de
la diplomatie en fait c'est alors
justement sur la centrale de zaporigia
la centrale nucléaire Vladimir Poutine
lui a dit aujourd'hui qu'il était ouvert
un dialogue il a vu d'ailleurs le patron
de l'IA Raphaël grossit qui était qui a
Saint-Pétersbourg on va les écouter
nous sommes très heureux de vous voir et
nous serons heureux de discuter de
toutes les questions qui nous
intéressent mutuellement ou qui peuvent
nous inquiéter par exemple concernant la
situation autour de la centrale
nucléaire de zaporigia en tout cas nous
sommes ouverts à ce dialogue et nous
sommes heureux de vous voir
nous avons des problèmes liés à la
sécurité nucléaire en particulier avec
la centrale de zapauridja
comme vous le savez j'ai mis en place
des efforts visant à empêcher un
accident nucléaire
un accident qui serait très nuisible et
en particulier dans cette région
générale il y a place au dialogue sur
cette autour de cette centrale de
zapporgia on a vu donc cette discussion
entre la lumière Poutine et donc Raphaël
grossi c'est possible quoi que je reste
tout à fait sceptique des discours de
Poutine généralement d'autant qu'il a
qu'il a fait enlever le directeur de la
centrale
ukrainienne il sait pas où il est
d'ailleurs
en prison donc si vous voulez
bon tant mieux si ça se passe mais je
demande à voir quand même c'est là on a
toute la preuve de la duplicité
diplomatique russe c'est-à-dire il y a
deux jours la Russie bombarde et tire
sur la centrale au point de détruire ces
systèmes d'approvisionnement en énergie
qui permettent d'assurer les fonctions
vitales de majorité de sûreté nucléaire
c'est-à-dire le refroidissement des
réacteurs et là aujourd'hui Poutine
reçoit Raphaël et grossi pour lui dire
on est prêt à s'occuper d'un alors que
il revendique
zapporija comme un territoire la
centrale j'entends comme un territoire
russe alors même qu'il n'occupe pas la
ville et qu'il a tenté d'annexer par
enfin qu'il a annexé par référendum
contre toute l'égalité internationale
l'aublaste des abris de jazz sans avoir
même eu accès à la centrale donc en fait
on a là la totalité de la duplicité la
parole politique russe qui se déploie
dans toute sa splendeur avec une
probabilité de succès qui est nul c'est
à dire que Raphaël est grossi fait tous
les efforts possibles et imaginables
mais la dernière fois qu'il a mené une
mission d'inspection sur le site il a
quand même prouvé avec des équipes
internationales et l'accord de la Russie
que les équipes sur la centrale étaient
sous des menaces de pression
psychologique voire physique qui était
susceptibles de menacer les fonctions
vitales du bon fonctionnement à la
Central et que c'en est suivi absolument
rien de la part des Russes pour
permettre l'élaboration de de solution à
commencer par une zone de protection
autour de la centrale pour que celle-ci
ne fasse pas l'objet alors lui dit bien
sûr la plus grande centrale nucléaire
d'Europe
et s'il continue à dialoguer avec
Poutine c'est que peut-être il a un
espoir que finalement ils finiront par
en faire une zone justement des
nucléarisée je crois qu'il est
par son rôle il est obligé d'essayer de
garder les canaux de discussion ouvert
envie de discuter et c'est effectivement
un signe de duplicité et pour faire
croire que lui est de bonne volonté
contrairement à l'Ukraine mais il n'en
ai rien puisque cette centrale est bien
sur le territoire ukrainien Tatiana une
réaction justement sur cette ce dialogue
entre Poutine et grossi je serais
d'accord absolument d'accord avec ce que
les autres ont dit bien sûr c'est une
diversité de la part de
Poutine mais de la part de de grossir en
fait c'est bien sûr on comprend ce qui
est dans le corps de l'intérêt de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique c'est la sécurité nucléaire de
la région parce que on sait très bien
que le nucléaire ça connaît pas de
frontières etc donc c'est pour éviter
des problèmes des accidents etc mais
l'intérêt de l'Ukraine est celui-ci bien
sûr sécuritaire mais aussi de reprendre
centrale je rappelle que c'est la plus
grande centrale en Europe donc hier
l'Ukraine après les bombardements bien
sûr le canard cessé d'exporter
l'électricité à l'étranger ce qu'il
faisait durant des mois donc ça sa nuit
à l'économie
ukrainienne et donc l'intérêt de
l'Ukraine est bien sûr c'est la reprise
la reprise de la station la reprise est
tout à fait juste parce que c'est il
s'agit bien du session
ukrainienne qui est située dans les
torreur
Ukrainiens donc pour nous la solution
serait bien sûr dans un premier étape de
ça c'est assuré la sécurité mais ensuite
de reprendre la station et de reprendre
toutes les régions nos apports quelle
place pour la diplomatie juste une
question justement autour de de
erdo one puisque le président turc a dit
vouloir rencontrer Vladimir Poutine à
Astana jeudi donc en marge d'un sommet
régional dans la capitale du Kazakhstan
Régis commence par vous donc qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire qu'effectivement ils
vont peut-être se mettre d'accord alors
il y a eu cet accord sur le céréales les
céréales pourquoi est-ce que tout d'un
coup Erdogan je voudrais voir Poutine à
Astana non lui il essaie de jouer un
rôle de de d'intermédiaire dans la
région c'est un acteur si j'ose dire du
monde multipolaire dans lequel on vit en
vie aujourd'hui et on voit monsieur
erdoan sur sur tous les fronts surtout
les les flancs en tout cas donc il est
il est 7 jours de jouer ce rôle s'il
peut être porteur de pêche effectivement
ça ira sur son régime sur l'image de de
son pays dans quelle mesure il peut y
arriver je pense qu'il la situation
n'est pas du tout
en l'état ouverte à une négociation ni
de la part de la Russie qui est
absolument
intransigeante et ni de la part de
l'Ukraine qui est sur le terrain du
front sud et est de l'Ukraine et
remporte des victoires et n'a aucune
envie pour le moment de de baisser la
garde il pourrait peut-être évoquer
parce que le problème des réfugiés
russes en Turquie parce qu'il y en a un
grand nombre qui sont arrivés en Turquie
et ça pourrait être un des sujets de
discussion
ça peut être évoqué je dis pas que ça
sera le sujet principal mais ça peut
être évoqué
une diplomatie justement avec
erdo One comme médiateur ça vous semble
quelque chose de de réalisme
difficile de dire mais ce qui est très
clair c'est que maintenant ce n'est plus
la France et l'Allemagne qui était
médiateur dans le conflit sa première
phase donc en 2014 15 avec le format
Normandie avec les accords de misk donc
là on voit que le centre de médiation se
passait un peu plus à l'est avec Erdogan
oui bien sûr il essaye de jouer son rôle
de médiateur parfois avec succès il faut
admettre aussi parce que avec le avec
les céréales avec échanges aussi de
défenseur d'as obstacles c'est parti
partiellement grâce à son rôle d'Erdogan
donc comme médiateur que ça a marché je
rappelle que sans qu'elle commandant de
d'Azov sont actuellement en Turquie
c'est vrai cette procédure d'extraction
et de il devrait rester en Turquie
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre mauvaise
surprise pour les réfugiés russes qui
sont là de voir les les nazis comme il
le croit à zoo veut être aussi un
Turquie bon bref
Erdogan essaie de monter monter
diplomatiquement et et je dirais avec
certains succès parce que d'une part
bien sûr le soutien de la Turquie est
important pour l'Ukraine avec pas mal de
dossiers bactar les drones et aide
militaire mais pas toutes les sanctions
et je dirais même très peu de sanctions
et à la fois essayer de négocier avec
Poutine donc ils essaient de jouer ce
rôle de négociateur c'est un rôle aussi
nécessaire pendant la guerre en tout cas
de jouer sa carte merci beaucoup Tatiana
au gardekova d'avoir été avec toi en
direct de Kiev merci Thomas Friant merci
Régis Régis Gentet Merci à VOUS général
keno merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis pour ce débat donc sur la riposte
occidentale après ces bombardements
russes en Ukraine vous restez avec nous
sur France 24